die strahlende silhouette von singapur
der finanz drehscheibe von asian und
eine der teuersten städte der welt
in singapur treffen privates
unternehmertum und geld aufeinander ein
großteil der erfolgsgeschichte asiens
geht auf privates unternehmertum zurück
asien wächst bei nacht wenn die
regierung schläft bis zu 60 prozent
aller projekte in asien werden über die
banken singapurs finanziert
die privatwirtschaft hat ihre wünsche
der stadt hingegen ist für sein volk
verantwortlich und muss ihr vermitteln
damit alles zusammenpasst wenn
wir privatwirtschaft und öffentlicher
hand bündeln können wir die nötigen
mittel für diese projekte aufbringen
die finanzierung der infrastruktur ist
eine der herausforderungen für die
nächste generation in asien
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin haslinger armen willkommen in
singapur der stadtstaat macht mit knapp
sechs millionen einwohnern weniger als
ein prozent der bevölkerung von asian
aber fast zwölf prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung aus singapur ist das
zentrum für finanzen und infrastruktur
südost asiens
etwas wie singapur gibt es irgendwo
sonst in der region
die kleine insel ist über den größten
flughafen der region und in zweit
größten containerhafen der welt mit dem
rest der welt verbunden
die stadt bietet hochentwickelte
finanzmärkte bildung und fachkompetenz
in asien gibt es sowohl kleine länder
die in der entwicklung hinterherhinken
als auch auf der anderen seite
hochmoderne industrienationen wie
singapur die am völlig anderen ende des
spektrums stehen
also einen homogenen markt mit homogenem
kaufverhalten und gleiche chancen
anzunehmen spiegelt offensichtlich nicht
die realität wider
investoren aus aller welt sagen zur
investition in den asian immer wieder
ihre entscheidung viele für in china
anders aus als für thailand oder
singapur
daran scheitert es in der realität
leider oft
die bs ist die grösste bank südostasiens
die hälfte ihrer geschäfte entfällt auf
singapur und die hälfte ihres umsatzes
stammt aus institutional banking ein
großteil der erfolgsgeschichte asiens
geht auf privates unternehmertum zurück
asien wächst bei nacht wenn die
regierung schläft für mich ist die
privatwirtschaft die treibende kraft der
integration
die firmen streben danach
grenzübergreifend zusammenzuarbeiten und
die verbraucher wir in ihrerseits mit
den füßen wehren
die privatwirtschaft und einzelpersonen
treiben die geschichte voran und nehmen
dabei die regierung und den staatlichen
sektor
die meisten regierungen wollen das
gleiche ihr volk glücklich machen wofür
sie infrastruktur brauchen
verschiedene länder verfolgen hierbei
verschiedene ansätze
manche verlassen sich stark auf die
privatwirtschaft andere setzen auf
staatliche betriebe
ich bin ein verfechter öffentlich
privater partnerschaften
wir engagieren uns auf diese art auf den
philippinen und ich glaube dass der
private sektor insbesondere in
anbetracht seines wachsenden budgets in
der pflicht steht sich gewissenhaft und
mit gebotenem ernst an bisher
üblicherweise staatlichen projekten zu
beteiligen
man muss es aus der perspektive der
privatwirtschaft ziehen sie werden nur
handeln wenn die projekte eine
angemessene rendite versprechen
hat man das geschafft muss man dafür
sorgen dass alles gut strukturiert ist
wobei auch der regulatorische rahmen der
investitionen von bedeutung ist
die asiatische entwicklungsbank rechnet
für die infrastruktur bedürfnisse in
asien mit erforderlichen ausgaben von
3,1 billionen dollar in zehn jahren
eine zentrale anlaufstelle eingerichtet
[Musik]
der ausbau der kompetenzen der länder
ist auch von bedeutung
denn die beamten oder anderweitige
verantwortliche eines landes müssen
imstande sein ein vorgeschlagenes
strukturiertes projekt einschätzen zu
können
findet man will hier nicht nur ein
projekt umsetzen sondern seinem volk
einen mehrwert bieten also arbeitsplätze
den austausch von fachwissen und
natürlich die direkten vorteile des
projekts
die beiden bereiche müssen
zusammenarbeiten
denn der staatssektor muss sich
schließlich sowohl bei den richtlinien
als auch bei der infrastruktur mit der
privatwirtschaft koordinieren die
öffentliche hand muss also an der
entwicklung von zahlungs mechanismen
blieben sowie an der harmonisierung von
kapitalmärkten beteiligt sein
ohne zusammenarbeit geht es nicht auch
wenn die privatwirtschaft oft
federführend sein wird
singapur ist für viele länder ein
vorbild
nicht nur in asien sondern auf der
ganzen welt
insbesondere im hinblick darauf dass die
öffentliche hand sehr darauf bedacht ist
sich bestmöglich auf trends in der
privatwirtschaft und weltweit
beobachtete entwicklungen einzustellen
sam and group ist eine der größten
konzerne thailands das
infrastrukturunternehmen ist seit über
100 jahren in der region von asian aktiv
die glasfront des hauptsitzes erlaubt
einen blick auf den hauptbahnhof von
bangkok der bald schnellzug linien von
singapur bis nach china verbinden wird
thailand investiert stark in
infrastruktur ebenso wie es auch länder
wie vietnam und indonesien tun
wir beobachten auch den trend die
infrastrukturen der länder von asien mit
china zu vernetzen
wir gehen also davon aus dass der
schwerpunkt zumindest staatlicher
investitionen in den kommenden zehn
jahren auf der infrastruktur liegen wird
die länder wollen für die aufstrebende
mittelschicht städte bauen große wie
kleine
sie müssen also viele städte planen und
dabei alles mögliche bedenken
abfallmanagement hygiene
wasserversorgung elektrizität und
kommunikation sind einige der
wiederkehrenden kernpunkte in den
ländern rund um singapur
wenn wir privatwirtschaft und
öffentlicher hand bündeln können wir die
nötigen mittel für diese projekte
aufbringen
die meisten länder in asien hätten bei
der infrastruktur entwicklung hinterher
was kommt was auch am logans werten
starken wachstum liegt doch die massive
verstädterung wie wir sie in den
großstädten manila jakarta und bangkok
beobachten können offenbart uns wie groß
der bedarf an zukunftsfähige
infrastruktur tatsächlich ist
jedes land braucht einen
maßgeschneiderten ansatz im
hochentwickelten singapur haben wir es
mit ganz anderen herausforderungen zu
tun als beispielsweise in birma laos
oder kambodscha
darum passen wir unsere herangehensweise
für die jeweiligen länder und ihre
bedürfnisse an damit wir die richtigen
lösungen anbieten können
vor 130 jahren installierte general
electric auf den philippinen die erste
glühbirne
als nächstes sehen wir uns die
energieversorgung für die zukunft von
asian an
65 millionen menschen ein zehntel der
bevölkerung lebt ohne elektrizität in
manchen ländern hat nicht mal ein
drittel strom
[Musik]
asien ist im wandel nicht nur bei der
vernetzung und inklusion sondern auch in
sachen nachhaltigkeit
kohle ist hier der hauptlieferant für
strom doch der bedarf ist in den letzten
15 jahren um 60 prozent gestiegen
[Musik]
65 millionen menschen ein zehntel der
bevölkerung lebt ohne elektrizität
in manchen ländern hat nicht mal ein
drittel strom in singapur wiederum 100
prozent die energiegewinnung muss daher
unbedingt ausgebaut werden
wir fokussieren uns auf diesen bereich
und bieten glücklicherweise ein
vollständiges portfolio an erneuerbaren
lösungen wind sonne energie speicher
aber auch thermische technologien wie
gas und kohle
jedes land hat seine eigene situation
und eigene ressourcen manche haben keine
ressourcen und müssen importieren darum
brauchen sie alle individuelle lösungen
damit die länder der region ihr
potenzial entfalten können brauchen sie
energieversorgung was sind hierbei die
herausforderungen
das problem ist dass die
energieversorgung in der vergangenheit
über herkömmliche fossile energieträger
folgte jetzt aber wurde klimaschutz und
nachhaltigkeit ein großes thema mit
gutem grund
den energiebedarf und das verlangen nach
nachhaltigkeit ins gleichgewicht zu
bringen ist die herausforderung
glücklicherweise haben sich
preisunterschied und kosteneffizienz
erneuerbarer energien in den letzten
fünf jahren stark verbessert
somit sehen wir eine chance den anteil
erneuerbarer energien deutlich zu
erhöhen
lg chem
die aya miyama group ist eines der
ältesten und größten konglomerate der
philippinen die energie-sparte arbeitet
an milliardenschweren projekten für
erneuerbare energiequellen auf den
philippinen indonesien und in vietnam
hat sich das ziel gesetzt bis 2025 23
prozent seines stroms aus erneuerbaren
quellen zu beziehen die meisten
regierungen haben mittlerweile ein viel
stärkeres bewusstsein dafür und streben
nach erneuerbarer energie wir müssen
unser portfolio entsprechend anpassen
und sonst hier stärker einbringen die
deckung des energiebedarfs auf
nachhaltige weise ist die große
herausforderung sowohl für die
privatwirtschaft als auch für die
öffentliche hand
das ziel der nachhaltigkeit musste man
schon immer als gleichgewicht betrachten
der klimawandel ist ein großes problem
wohl das größte problem der nächsten 10
15 jahre aber auch hier gibt es nicht
die radikale antwort wäre sämtliche
nutzung fossiler energieträger
einzustellen südostasien wird aber in
den kommenden zehn fünfzehn jahren
gewaltigen energiebedarf haben weshalb
es heute keine echte alternative dazu
gibt
banken wie die ubs und die wollen nur
noch grüne nachhaltige projekte
unterstützen
lassen eine region die nach günstige
energie verlangt realistisch für kohle
noch die vorherrschende energiequelle
ist
ich denke die welt und auch die banken
tun hier das richtige und verlagern den
fokus hin zur nachhaltigkeit
wir haben unsererseits das langfristige
ziel dass die hälfte der
energieproduktion unseres portfolios aus
nachhaltigen quellen stammen zahl
es geht immer um ein gleichgewicht ich
sehe mich nicht als radikal
es sollte in richtung erneuerbarer
energiequellen gehen aber es gibt
anwendungsfälle bei denen fossile
energieträger noch immer die
effizienteste lösung
wir müssen es war den energiebedarf
unserer zeit decken können aber nicht
ewig so weitermachen da die zukunft
sonst düster aussieht
brauchen wir die balance und müssen dann
den anteil thermischer energie
verringern wobei auch banken eine
wichtige rolle spielen
wir müssen den menschen alternativen
also finanzieren wir verstärkt
erneuerbare projekte solarstrom
windenergie und auch die rohmasse
der us-gigant general electric sieht in
südostasien ein gewaltiges
wachstumspotential der umsatz des
unternehmens in der region hat sich in
acht jahren auf sieben milliarden dollar
verdoppelt das unternehmen hat in der
region 10.000 beschäftigte
die größte wachstumschance liegt in
enger zusammenarbeit der länder
miteinander in laos wird im norden viel
energie für den export nach vietnam und
thailand produziert während im süden
viel energie aus vietnam und thailand
importiert wird
das stromnetz ist also der schlüssel
dazu die energie am richtigen ort nutzen
zu können
in bezug auf die physische infrastruktur
und die vernetzung der länder
untereinander hat die region noch luft
nach oben
inklusives wachstum und inklusive
entwicklung stehen im fokus wie können
sie ländern wie indonesien einem
riesigen archiv mit 17.000 inseln helfen
die lücke zu schließen
indonesien ist ein interessantes
beispiel
hier sind sowohl große kraftwerke
erforderlich wie er auf java oder
sumatra in dicht besiedelten gebieten
als auch kleinere systeme auf fossiler
basis für die entlegenen regionen
wir haben erst kürzlich viele entlegene
inseln elektrifiziert mit größtenteils
autonomen mobilen
für die regierung war es ein großer
erfolg energie in regionen zu bringen
die vorher keine stromversorgung hatten
fast alle länder haben
infrastrukturpläne in höhe von hunderten
milliarden dollar und dennoch fehlt es
in südostasien markant an infrastruktur
was wäre die wichtigste maßnahme dagegen
das wachstum war so gewaltig dass wir
erst wieder aufholen müssen
mit infrastruktur können wir das
wachstum aber auf lange sicht
aufrechterhalten ich bin der ansicht
dass wir insbesondere in
wirtschaftlichen schwerpunkten die
infrastruktur vorausschauend und mit
ausreichend reserven ausbauen sollten um
das wachstum aufrechterhalten
regierungen müssen hierbei aber auch
politische und gesellschaftliche
probleme bedenken weshalb nicht immer
alles perfekt laufen kann
als nächstes betrachten wir vietnam den
wandel begrüßt
[Musik]
der größte nutzen von fynn tags sind
verringert die kosten für so gut wie
alles technologie ist grundsätzlich
deflationär die kosten für zugang und
transaktionen sinken kunden können
bessere angebote bekommen
wenn die kosten also sinken können auch
weniger weit entwickelte länder eine
bessere abdeckung ihrer finanzsysteme
erreichen
ich sehe hier keine nachteile
unsere länder arbeiten daran
geschäftstätigkeiten zu erleichtern
und ebenso über gesetze und richtlinien
firmen die richtigen anreize zu bieten
in diesen ländern zu investieren
es ist nicht einfach über landesgrenzen
und vor allem steuer und rechts bereiche
hinweg tätig zu sein
[Musik]
das ist meiner meinung nach unsere
aktuell größte herausforderung
die großen städte in asien werden sich
stark modernisieren und smart cities
werden sie werden sich an die
anforderungen der zukunft anpassen
nachhaltiger und umweltfreundlicher
werden mit weniger stau auf der straße
es gibt bis dahin noch viel zu tun aber
die art wie städte funktionieren und mit
energie versorgt werden wird sich in den
nächsten jahren drastisch ändern
wenn es bei öffentlich privaten
partnerschaften um wirklich
gesellschaftlich nützliche themen wie
öffentlichen nahverkehr geht
grundlegende infrastruktur für die
verbindung von menschen und wirtschaft
wird daraus eine inklusive komponente
die menschen in allen bereichen betrifft
insbesondere in den unteren
gesellschaftsschichten in
großen städten sind nahverkehrsprojekte
besonders wichtig da es in südostasien
sonst sehr schwierig ist sich in der
stadt zu bewegen major cities
[Musik]
das erwartete wirtschaftswachstum
philippinen wurde für 2009 10 mit fast 7
von den fünf größten volkswirtschaften
von asian am höchsten eingeschätzt
vietnam gehört nicht zu ihnen ist aber
auf einem ähnlichen kurs
ich befasse mich jetzt schon seit über
20 jahren mit vietnam und könnte den
wandel weg von strikter staatlicher
kontrolle hin zu einer flexibleren
marktwirtschaft mit privatkapital
deutlich beobachten
die richtung scheint klar aber sie haben
noch einen weiten weg vor sich
verglichen mit den marktorientierten
asien staaten ist es in vietnam immer
noch deutlich schwerer etwas auf die
beine zu stellen
sie intensivieren ihr investment in
erneuerbare energien in vietnam warum
sie boten investoren für kurze zeit
reizvolle zelle und gebühren wenn man
überlegt wo man investieren will und
eine regierung plötzlich anreize schafft
zieht das natürlich kapital an
vietnam war sehr offen für spezifische
nachhaltige projekte
wir hatten das know-how ein geeignetes
team und die finanziellen mittel das
projekt durchzuführen
also sagten wir zu
sein ist eine interessante region und
vietnam war bezüglich der investitions
angebote sehr großzügig also ergriffen
wir die chance und machten uns ans werk
zum großen projekten fällt mir als
erstes unsere beteiligung am petrochemie
komplex in südvietnam
heim-team in statt
da ging es um knapp 5,4 milliarden us
dollar
der bau hat bereits begonnen ein zehntel
ist schon geschafft
wir rechnen damit dass es in drei oder
vier jahren kommerziell in betrieb gehen
kann
es ist der erste petrochemische komplex
in vietnam
herausforderungen wir zuerst mit etwas
positivem an bevor wir von den problemen
reden
die region macht sich sehr gut das
gesamtwachstum in südostasien ganz asien
ist ein strahlendes vorbild und wird das
auch noch eine weile bleiben
die herausforderung besteht darin das
wachstum nachhaltig planbar und
langfristig haltbar zu machen
wir sehen faszinierende entwicklungen
wie gewaltige urbanisierung was
natürlich eine infrastruktur
herausforderung darstellt das lässt sich
in allen großen städten südost asiens
beobachten
es gibt mittlerweile etwa 1800 flugzeuge
in asien in den nächsten zehn jahren
werden nochmal 2200 dazu kommen das hört
sich also mehr als verdoppeln ebenso die
energieversorgung heute haben wir eine
leistung von 260 gigawatt und in den
nächsten zehn jahren kommen noch mal 200
gigawatt dazu das gleiche im
gesundheitswesen das wächst auch seit
jahren stetig um etwa zehn prozent in
der region sind tausende neue
krankenhäuser geplant
auch die vernetzung der menschen wird
besser
das liegt zum teil an technologien die
es uns erlauben kulturelle und
sprachliche barrieren einfacher zu
überwinden
für mich persönlich ist das
die bedeutendste verbesserung die ich
zwischen den ländern von asian in den
letzten vier oder fünf jahren beobachten
konnte
ein großer unterschied ist die
verbreitung von marken aus asien
gerade im technologiesektor treten
marken aus asien immer stärker in den
vordergrund
anders als früher das hat sich geändert
die andere veränderung ist der wunsch
und das behutsame streben nach markt
integration
beim handel von waren und
dienstleistungen haben die länder mit
niedrigen zöllen und geringen
handelsbarrieren viel erreicht die
integration steigt marken breiten sich
aus kapitalmärkte und menschen müssen
noch stärker integriert werden arbeits
mobilität ist noch ein problem
starts politik und privates
unternehmertum innerhalb und über
grenzen hinweg partnerschaften und
geteilter wohlstand im namen des volkes
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit bei asia
next generation
[Musik]